build-it draw flag
Vsauce this is your home for some of the
coolest creations from everyday people
this is bidipi building Bruno has been
building his own amusement park in the
woods of Italy for the last 40 years
IPO P is a restaurant in Battaglia Italy
that he opened in 1969 and when he
couldn't find a welder to make some
hooks that he needed he taught himself
to weld bruno started creating these
rides to build surrounding the
restaurant and to date they include zip
lines roller coasters tilt awhirl x'
swings and slides for both children and
adults
Katie McGuire makes beautiful sculptures
out of bird feathers such as this one
from rooster feathers one made from
mallard feathers a combination of Dove
and Swan feathers and this one from crow
feathers and she says she likes using
well-known materials an unexpected way
to play with the senses embodying ethics
endangered is a project by Rohan Chhabra
where hunting jackets transform into
animals under attack from illegal
poaching and he's hoping to raise
awareness for this important issue some
of the jackets include the Saiga
antelope Asian elephant gorilla rhino
and Tiger Mike Iverson of blind squirrel
props creates incredible weapons helmets
and other props from comics anime movies
and video games like this Dragon Ball Z
Scouter an AEP 7 laser pistol from
fallout boromir's shield from Lord of
the Rings
a game of Thrones dragon egg BPRD pistol
from the Hellboy comic at this
submachine gun it comes with
step-by-step instructions that you can
download and try for yourself draw it
radiology art was created by physician
and artists a terse tulké he made them
while in medical school because he
wanted to see the interior structures of
everyday objects and ultimately hopes to
make it easier for patients to relate to
the Radiological procedures that they go
through his works include electronics
toys and even food Tom creates cool
cartoon like street art some examples of
his work include nerd power my little ki
Joe right to housing and haircut check
out his website for more great street
art sculptures and paintings and now for
some pieces from the say hi to the bad
guy art show celebrating cult villain
Michael Paul Smith creates these scenes
with old cars using forced perspective
by setting up tiny model cars and scenes
on card tables he photographs them from
the perfect angle to seamlessly blend
them into the environment and he's been
creating a fictional small town he calls
Elgin Park plyatt uncommon good sells
these major scale musical wine glasses
which sound like this
one Tesla creates Tesla coil kits and
here's one playing the theme from
Pirates of the Caribbean
awesome shredder eric calderone aka 311
erock takes on the music of spider-man
Oh
finally here's the video for infinity
collar by grooms featuring a crowdsource
collaboration with various animators
you
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo gun
click here listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to just your creations and as
always thanks for watching